i'm so excited because
we are ending our new york premiere week
with a very special guest today he's
probably he is
such an epic grammy emmy tony award
winning actor
who recently reprised his iconic
broadway role in the musical adaptation
um in film of dear evan hansen um today
also happens to be his birthday so
that's cool too so
in honor of his musicality i'm hoping we
can sing him happy birthday
um please welcome this extremely
talented and someone who's able to
challenge humanity better than any actor
i've ever seen in my life ben platt
[Applause]
i am so happy to see you i'm happy to
see you too hi maria funny enough i
started stalking you early
um
and a lot of it was motivated by the
dear evan hansen because
i got to see you in the show
but like you purged on a daily basis for
that show i've never seen anything like
it how did you get yourself there
it's a question that i'm still figuring
out how to answer many years later i
mean i think
it was different every day because
theater's such a live organic changing
thing i feel like the main reason why it
was doable to kind of muster that every
day was because i saw firsthand every
day how it was affecting people and how
moved people were especially young
people by the story and how more than
any piece of art that i've ever had the
privilege of being involved in it really
changed people's paths like they would
walk in and then walk out different in
some way and and it would start
conversations intergenerational
conversations especially between parents
and kids and all of that just felt so
much bigger than my own physical
exhaustion or whatever emotional
exhaustion and so if there ever was ever
a day where i got to the theater and i
was like how am i going to climb this
mountain today or how am i going to make
this happen today i would read some of
the beautiful letters that transcend i
would look online and see you know
people who are coming for the first time
who had been waiting months to be there
just reminding myself that this has such
a greater power than than me
when you spread the message of this film
it's so unifying and now that it is a
film
you don't have to miss it if you can't
get to broadway and i love that and i
was just so relieved that this story
would continue to have
the life that it has me too
um
something that um
has had a little bit of a life of its
own with
that i've been a part of
and there's a budding uh journalist um
in high school uh
that gets to um interview the cast of
your your film oh yes at the press
junket yes i loved meeting her okay
great well let's take a look um at this
hi everyone
hi drew hi ben
it's me josie geller and thanks for
trusting me with this very important job
of talking to the cast of dear evan
hansen
i'm so excited i'm a little nervous but
mostly excited
and i've always wanted to be a
journalist and this is a really great
resume builder
wow i can't believe i'm here with
cameras and everything
wish me luck
i'm here with the cast
of dear evan hansen
thank you guys for letting me ask you
some questions
um you were singing live
on film right yeah we did we did we got
to sing in person in in dining rooms and
bedrooms and living rooms and school
hallways and
to each other in each other's faces
when you were in high school what did
you want to be amandla
i wanted to be a director
oh
you're going to do it yeah
i wanted to be a doctor oh
i'm probably not going to do it
[Laughter]
i think you're healing people just fine
i wanted to be an actor on broadway
oh well
i think that's what they call the
definition of irony
[Laughter]
danny josie i wanted to be so many
things i wanted to be a baseball player
i wanted to be a lawyer
but ultimately deep down
i really wanted to be an actor i'm glad
you found your dream
me too thank you
i feel like julianne's going to think
i'm saying that just because i like to
repeat everything she says because i
love her so much
but i also wanted to be a doctor but i
couldn't pass chemistry so i had to look
in like the things that i had an
aptitude for so i went into dance
actually
um i'm wearing my prom dress did anyone
go to prom or have a prom story you're
not in your head i didn't go to prom it
was really fun and i went with my best
friend beenie feldstein who is also an
actor and she was my date
um and for our prom photo we both did
the arms that eva peron does
like this
amandla um
it was probably my gayest moment in all
of high school
i went in a suit i took my best friend
he was a girl
and um i felt very comfortable and proud
i went to prom i actually went to um to
four proms because i always had an older
boyfriend but it was diminishing returns
so by the time i got to be a senior i
didn't have a boyfriend so i had to go
with my best friend's brother kenny and
i had to ask him i was like come on
kenny
how about you amy my boyfriend's mother
sewed my dress and it was i remember it
was like teal green crushed velvet with
like
i loved it so much i felt like such a
grown-up what sounds like something in
my closet
danny did you go to prague i did i did
go to prom and
i
married my prom date
that's quite a prom story
congratulations
i believe in the movie world they call
that a true payoff
i really
love
this story because
i think
we're just fighting really hard to be
ourselves
and i was just wondering as a last
question
for anybody out there
who feels lost trying to get
to their true self and maybe they make a
big mess of it along the way what is one
thing you would say to just
be okay with being you
what i love in the movie
about julianne and ben's relationship is
julianne's character has so much
unconditional love for her son
and i would say to myself that
you are deserving of love just by
being a person who is here on this
planet
i like that i love that maybe i would
say
that uncertainty can be part of who you
are that you don't have to make a hard
decision or a hard choice you don't have
to have all the answers about who you
are and there's no finish line of like i
am who i am and i've reached that point
i think
any kind of
struggle or direction or journey towards
that as long as that's your intent and
that's what you're moving towards and
that's your kind of north star then i
think that is being authentically
yourself even if what that looks like
continues to change all the time
thank you so much for letting me come to
your press junket
this is josie gala reporting from south
glen south videography club
for dear evan hansen thank you
[Applause]
that really was a dream collaboration of
a lifetime yeah i'm so happy we can
finally give it away that i got to meet
her i love your answer about
your
uncertainty yeah but i feel like that's
an underrated thing you brought up for
sure i feel like there is a great
concern all across the board in our
modern current time with black and white
and yes and no and right and wrong and
cancel this and cancel that there's a
lot of finite things that we're all
craving and i feel like
we have to refine the comfortability
with nuance and with gray area and
giving ourselves the grace to still be
figuring things out and not have hard
answers and hard choices and decisions
about who we are and not
having no ability to go back on those
things or rethink those things i feel
like comfortability in that unknown and
uncertainty as you said is like
by definition that's being yourself i
think it's it's admitting that you know
nothing is
perfect and nothing is finite and
everything is always in progress and
like that to me is way more authentic
than somebody saying here are the three
things about who i am and those are
never going to change because everything
changes i mean who knew that we would
all be in a pandemic for two years and
then everybody would be here wearing
masks like we could have never known
that so i feel like giving yourself the
space and the grace to change and learn
and grow and change your mind and take
things back and make mistakes and be
forgiven for them like that's where i
think we all need to focus a little more
hopefully wow
wow wow
[Music]